Comparison among labels,
just look at a quick example.
L1 is TS and itss compartment has
these three categories, A, B and C.
L2 is secret with A, B and L3 is secret
also with B, C, D as their categories.
So does L1 dominate L2?
TS is dominate S and
A, B, C contains A, B.
So, we said that each,
for L1 to dominate L2,
the sensitivity level has to be greater,
which is the case,
and its compartment has to contain the
compartment of L2, which is the case.
So this is, yes.
Does L2 is less than L1?
Yes, the same reasoning we did.
It's less because this is less than
TS and this is containing that.
How about L1 and L3?
As we know, TS is higher than S.
So when you look at the first part,
just the sensitivity level,
that's the total orders, so
this is greater than this.
But B, C, D is not contained in A,
B, C, okay?
So there's this element D
that's not contained here and
because this is not contained here
then L1 is not greater than L3.
Similarly, L3 is not greater than L1,
and the two are not equal because
the compartments are different and
the sensitude level is different.
So, when neither one dominates
the other one and they are not equal,
then they can not be compared, which is
the third case that we're talking about.